from bloomberg quick take i'm renita
young and this is your money story
now we are still in women's history
month and today i want to introduce you
to
paula pant of afford anything a growing
personal finance community that's
already pretty large more than 65 000
subscribers
to her newsletter as well as millions
who have downloaded
the afford anything podcast and today we
will talk about how women can achieve
financial success
and financial independence paula come on
in
and welcome to the show thank you thank
you so much for having me
absolutely so of course here on your
money story we start with your money
story
and i want to talk about how you've you
grew up the child of immigrants
and you saw how frugal your parents were
growing up after
you guys immigrated here from nepal tell
me how that
shaped the way that you related to money
in your early adulthood
sure absolutely so my parents uh i was
born in kathmandu nepal
i was two months old when my when i came
to the united states
and so i watched my parents as i was
young
they went through uh that that getting
started that getting established you
know they
shortly before i was born they bought
their very first car ever
um it was after i was born that they
moved out of an apartment and we got
a very small home uh you know a small
starter home that my
dad didn't even have the money for a
down payment so he had to borrow the
money from someone that he worked with
to get the down payment to get into the
starter home
and so um now you know now that i'm an
adult i see a lot of my friends
uh worried that you know oh i'm 35 and i
haven't hit
x goal yet or i'm i'm 40 and i haven't
hit
x goal yet and i think back to my
parents
who all of these milestones you know
oftentimes in the united states people
get a
their first car at 16. my parents got
their first car at like 43.
so um so i just watched my parents go
through these milestones
later in life my dad opened his first
retirement account when he was 50.
and uh and we were very frugal because
we had to be
and so a lot of that that chasing status
symbols of
you know designer brand handbags or nice
cars that just wasn't in our
consciousness we never felt deprived
it just wasn't part of our lives and
likewise it wasn't necessarily in your
consciousness
either but you
obviously were not always financially
independent you became so
in your adulthood but take me to
the moment when you started to think
that maybe i can
i can go about this differently it
happened when you graduated from high
school right
uh when i graduated from college college
pardon me
yeah when i when i was in college i
really wanted to study abroad
that was a big goal except study abroad
programs were prohibitively expensive
they were
15 to twenty thousand dollars for a
single semester
and so my thinking being someone who's
who's
naturally frugal um my thinking was you
know what i
i honestly i don't wanna study i just
wanna go abroad
but if i uh graduate
work for a few years save up some money
i could then quit my job and go travel
and i could do it for a fraction of the
cost
and so that was always my plan and so as
when i was in my early 20s and a lot of
my friends
were trading up to you know getting
nicer apartments with
uh you know we're nicer cars or they
were going out and
buying uh you know 14 drinks at
bars i was instead focused on
saving as much money as possible in a
travel fund
um and so that was i think probably the
point in my money story where
i i got very clear on what my goals were
even though those goals were different
from what society says they should be
i became obsessed with saving money for
a specific goal
despite the fact that that meant that i
wasn't quote unquote keeping up with the
joneses
got it and so i understand you did this
by any freelance gig that you had you
chucked the money away in savings um
eventually saving up
enough to go abroad and so
this all kind of points us to afford
anything
you have a philosophy that says you can
afford anything
but not everything can you first explain
to
us what what do you say that means and
how it relates to not just your money
with the rest of your life
sure absolutely so uh when i uh
you're absolutely correct so over the
span of three years i managed to save up
twenty five thousand dollars
um and and once i did once i had that
money i
quit my job and i went to go travel and
when that happened
my friends often said i would love to do
that but i can't afford it that was the
refrain that i heard over and over and
over
um but these were the same friends who i
knew worked in higher paying jobs than i
did
but they drove nicer cars they lived in
nicer apartments
and so that was where i really came up
with this philosophy
that you can afford anything but not
everything
meaning every choice that you make
carries a trade-off
saying yes to something implicitly being
saying no to all other opportunities and
that doesn't just
apply to your money that applies to your
time to your energy to your focus to
where you direct your attention
so it applies to every decision that you
make in your life
and what happens is that often uh i find
that we're unconscious of these
trade-offs
you know some given opportunity may
sound
interesting like oh i would love to do x
y z i'd love to go to that concert
i would love to live in a bigger home
but um but we don't
pause and think about what am i giving
up in order to do this
so uh the the affordability philosophy
was really born
of making that question clear that makes
sense
when you think about it you can't afford
everything but you can afford
anything and so talk just a little bit
more
about how this um how you can how you
apply
this to your focus energy
and attention sure absolutely so
oh this has happened so many times
during my life um especially as i've
been navigating my career
uh when i the job that i quit when i
went to go travel
my peak income at the time that i quit
was 31 000
per year and so um i was freelancing on
the side i was freelancing during the
evenings and weekends
and at an hourly rate i was making
at that time up to 75 an hour at my peak
so here i was working this nine to five
day job that
in which i earned 31 000 a year but i
was making
much more money um on an hourly basis as
a freelancer and so
it became clear to me that that was
where the opportunity was
and uh as i ventured
after i quit that job and started
traveling i decided i was going to make
a go of being a freelancer full-time
and in that world i mean the
the amount of things you possibly could
do are endless
no shortage of do i grow my business
this way or that way do i spend more
time on
social media or on sending pitches do i
accept this particular uh gig
which is money immediately but it's kind
of low paying
or do i say no and you know despite the
fact that i don't have something else
and refocus that time on trying to find
something else that is higher paying
like
there there are endless decisions to
make and every single one has a
trade-off
and you've worked it to really work with
you
and the kind of life you want the kind
of schedule you want how you want to
spend your time
and so that's a lot of what you teach
people and we're talking about women
today for women's history month so a lot
of what you teach folks
on afford anything and so because it's
women's history month we know that
there is a strong case for women to
achieve financial success
and become financially independent what
is your case
for why women need to become financially
independent
oh well so i i define let's start with
the definition of financial independence
in in the way that i
define it the way that i understand it
is i see financial independence as
the point at which your potential
passive income which is typically
through investments
is enough to create a safety net it's
enough to cover but bare bones
um you know standard of living so that
and and particularly i think for women
there are many
times that women have to make when it
comes to trade-offs
have to make decisions about you know do
do i um
do i become a caregiver
for maybe an aging parent or an asian
grandparent or do i pursue this other
opportunity that would
you know would be a great career
opportunity but would require me to move
a thousand miles away from my family uh
and all people make that decision men
and women both
but you know we see we see those kinds
of decisions
come up throughout our lives
when financial independence is in the
picture
it removes some of the necessity from
that decision making so
um i define financial independence as
you know imagine if you had a sibling
and you know hopefully this would never
happen but imagine if your sibling
um becomes very ill and you want to
spend
six months taking an unpaid leave of
absence so that you can go take care of
that
of him or her uh you want
enough money through your investments
that you could at a minimum
buy groceries keep the lights on you
know you wouldn't be living large you
wouldn't be living your
your best dream life but you can at
least
take care of things keep the bills paid
keep the lights on
while you're attending to this other
thing that's very important
and i think that that you know for
everyone
and and particularly for women is um
it creates a safety net that is just
invaluable you're absolutely right i
mean
back when you said that women are more
likely to make those tough decisions of
where to live having to do caregiving
of family members child care even of
kids and even elder care women are still
more
more likely to need to make those
decisions and therefore
may need to quit a job may need to
reduce hours
and will need financial independence
something else that i found out that
these facts we probably know um but
i just want to name them because i
didn't i've never thought about this
as a reason why women need financial
independence statistically women live
longer than men
and earn less also the 2018 bureau of
labor
statistics report said that the median
weekly earnings for
full-time salaried women they're just 81
of what men earn and then also on top of
that women often faced
uh are often faced with discrimination
in terms of wages
and advancement opportunities add on the
layer of women of color
and it's even deeper situations so
there's obviously a very strong case
for why women need to be financially
independent and you just helped us lay
it out there
and so one part of your philosophy as
well
um i find that you had a very very
unique perspective on budgets
that not a lot of personal finance
experts actually
have and we know that as adults we
should have a budget because the right
thing to do as grown-ups
right what about people who hate
budgeting
what should they do well you're in good
company because i'm with you
um and so i i've developed this approach
that i refer to as the anti-budget
the anti-budget is very simple so the
first thing that you do is you decide
how much money you want to save and when
i say save in this context
i mean anything that improves your net
worth so it could be literal savings in
a savings account
it could be um money
like additional payments that you put
towards the debt
above and beyond the minimum payment
required it could be contributions to a
retirement account
any improvement of your net worth is
what i mean when i say save
so decide how much you want to save
whether and that could be either a raw
dollar amount
or it could be a proportion of your
income doesn't matter but choose what
that's going to be pull that off the top
first and then whatever is left over
is yours to spend and i think the
simplicity
of the anti-budget makes it more likely
that you'll follow through
because so many budgets demand that we
uh
excessively line itemize everything to
the point where we know exactly how much
money we're spending on toothpaste and
dog food
and like who has time for that and who
can stick with that
you know it's kind of like uh um
those those apps where i've downloaded
so many apps where i'm supposed to input
every single thing that i eat
all day and i stick with it for maybe a
week and a half and then i just i can't
yeah get at lunch yeah it can get
overwhelming you're right because
um yeah it's it's tracking every single
penny
um but it sounds like and correct me if
i'm wrong you prioritize spending even
even over paying the bills um
so it's the philosophy huh you just
you're not spending over
over paying the bills but you work
everything else in there and you've also
expanded your definition
of what savings is like you just said
before so
that makes sense of course and so
speaking of saving
what are some very practical ways people
can start saving right now women can
start
saving so this is a great question so
first of all
uh when i think of savings as a
framework um
there are fundamentally there are two
choices
you you what you want to do is grow the
gap
between what you earn and what you spend
and oftentimes the word savings has this
connotation of a reduction in spending
but i want to move away from that
connotation and focus on
increasing the gap between income and
spending and once we look at it
in that context then the best way to for
some people
depending on who you are um the the best
way to
save maybe to earn more um that's not
true for everybody and that's not true
in all contexts but
i want to make that clear because the
word saving just
it does have that connotation of a
reduction of spending and that's not
necessarily
always the best approach for everyone so
uh
if the goal is to increase the gap
between what you earn and what you spend
there there are fundamentally three ways
to do it you can either earn more
you could spend less or you could do a
combination of the two
now if we do want to talk about the
spend less side of the equation we'll
discuss that first
um oftentimes the discussion
in tends to center around consumer
discretionary purchases
so i think we tend to give undue focus
to these small tweaks that we can make
oh don't
go get manicures uh you know
and unfortunately those are
you know those are sort of the expenses
that happen in the margins
um and they can they're
they because of salience like it's easy
for them to come to mind and they're
easy adjustments to make and so
oftentimes the discussion i think
over focuses on those when in fact
the majority of spending in most u.s
households
are the big three housing transportation
food
so if you really want to cut back on
spending
those three areas you know reducing the
size of your home
um radically altering your
transportation maybe you go from a
two-car family to a one-hour family
you know harder adjustments to make i
mean we're talking about
selling your home and moving to
somewhere um to something that's that's
a thousand square feet smaller like
that's not an easy shift
right it's much more meaningful than
um you know than some of the consumer
discretionary stuff that tends to get
i think overemphasized okay uh you know
what those are all
pretty practical and they may be things
that people don't think about all the
time
um but we have a quick question from the
audience someone wants to know how
to invest your stemi check
all right so how to so fundamentally how
to invest your stimulus check is
how to invest how to invest any amount
of money particularly
you know if if you weren't expecting
this money and you don't need it to pay
your bills
right and so in order to approach that
the first question
that i've got for for everyone who's
wondering that is
do you have an adequate emergency fund
you know if not
that's your first priority and an
emergency fund should represent
at least three months of your ordinary
expenses
ideally six months if you really want to
be
very very taken care of you can even
increase that to eight or nine months
but somewhere in that window make sure
you've got a good emergency fund
that's first and foremost second
um the next question that i've got for
you is
what is the timeline of
of that investment so if you are
investing money
that you intend to use for retirement
um and if you are 25 years old
and you want to retire at 65 that
retirement is 40 years away
then you can invest that money in a very
different way
than someone who wants to invest that
money for the purpose of
of sending their child to college they
want to invest that money in a 529 plan
um so that their kid can go to college
in 15 years
right so the timeline associated uh with
that investment which
which is another way of saying the goal
associated with that investment
is going to in influence the type of
risk that's appropriate for that
investment okay
that makes sense because um
it's like you you have to have a plan
for it you know it depends on what your
desire is
with that money yeah you saying uh that
determines
you know how much of it you invest
whether you put it in the savings or
elsewhere right markets movie um
and so end in mind essentially right
it makes sense um and so i want to know
if you have any special investment
strategies
that women can can go ahead and use
right now
special investment strategies well i
mean i don't know how special it is but
here are a few of my favorites so
first um tax advantage accounts
these include 401ks 403bs iras roth iras
hsas if you have a health insurance plan
that's hsa
eligible um those types of tax
advantaged accounts
are uh enormous like they provide
in addition to getting the growth that
comes with
the fact that this money is invested in
the market um you
also have various tax advantages that
come from the very nature of these
accounts so
i absolutely encourage people to to look
to those types of accounts first
um if again if it's appropriate for the
timeline of the investment
uh low-cost passively managed
index funds are a favorite of mine
because um you know an an index fund is
a fund in which you are
not betting on a single company um so
it's not like buying an individual stock
in which you are
trying to assess if if tesla or nike or
coca-cola is going to do well
you are instead buying a big basket of
stocks that replicate an underlying
index
and that means that you will do ideally
as well as or as poorly as that
underlying index no better
no worse um and and
you know mutual funds also set out to
actively manage mutual funds also set
out to to
defray some of that risk by investing in
a basket of stocks
but actively managed mutual funds often
have very high expense ratios
uh meaning high fees that are not
necessarily justified
um and so you can get that same
diversification
but eliminate the fees by focusing on
uh index funds instead so tax advantaged
accounts
index funds great and it sounds like
those are really good a lot of
first-time investors and
and relatively experienced investors
watch your money story and
that sounds like it's pitched to both
the risk-averse
and the people who uh don't mind a
little bit of
risk um and so we're coming to a close
shortly but of course men and women
watch your money story
and so there are a lot of people
watching this who want to know how they
can do what
you did escape their nine to five
and so what's the single most important
thing
that people need to know before they do
this you wrote a book about it
i would say i'd say two things one is
however you plan on making money outside
of your normal nine-to-five
do that test drive that while you're
still
at your nine-to-five so during the
evenings the weekends
whatever you have some time off um test
drive your idea of how you're gonna make
money and this will this will do two
things
one is it will give you um
a little bit of extra money you know
some extra savings that will
buffer that transition but secondly and
honestly i think what's more important
is it gives you proof of concept right
if you have this idea of how you're
gonna make money outside of your nine to
five
you test it you see if it works if it
does work
great and if it doesn't you learn that
while you still have your day job and
then you can pivot you can tweak you can
iterate
while you still have the security of
that paycheck um
so that's that's the first thing that i
would say and the second thing is
is think big you know after you do leave
your nine to five
um you know be clear on if you're trying
to build a lifestyle business
versus you know something that that's
going to take outside funding
like it's it's fine to build a lifestyle
business and
um that's what i've done but just
because you're building a lifestyle
business doesn't mean that you
you need to necessarily think small like
you can
you can impact a number of people a
large number of people
and the greater impact that you have um
you know the more you make like not only
do you make money but
you help more people you build a team
you
you just you have more flexibility
as a result of not trying to do
everything yourself a lot of times
people who leave the nine to five
try to do everything on their own and
sometimes it's better to
you know bring in a team create a team
of people who
um who compensate for your weaknesses
and help you focus on your strengths
all right that that sounds really good
very well put and as you can hear we're
in a live
studio so you can hear a little bit of
the news happening
behind but before we end i have to ask
you about the concept of purpose
because that's included of course it's
woven into just about everything you
talk about
on your podcast and on your blog and
even when you're speaking at fincon
and so just how important is it um
that one understands what purpose means
to them
whenever they do consider uh escaping
that nine to five
so uh i mean purpose of course is
important but it's also
intimidating like you know the idea that
you need to find your purpose in life i
mean
okay i'll do that by lunch right like
um and so for anyone who's like i don't
know what my purpose is i don't know
what the meaning of my life is that's a
big question
um to anyone who feels that way what i
would say is
follow your curiosity if there's
something that you're curious about
follow that and see where it leads and
the more you do that the more you
continue to follow your curiosity
the more that i think your clarity
around purpose will slowly evolve over
time
i think that's a perfect way and place
to leave it paula pant of afford
anything thank you so much
for joining us and folks in the audience
if you want to learn more about afford
anything
you can find afford anything on social
platforms across the web
at afford anything this has been your
money story
from bloomberg quick take i'm renita
young have a wonderful day